[Captions by Y Translator]
In the past, we've done
some tests to see what happens
if we heat up dry ice
in a furnace, with a blowtorch,
or even by pouring molten metal onto it.
Today, we're going to see what happens
if we throw it in our mini Arc furnace,
which heats up several thousand
degrees hotter than any of those.
[Music]
YouTuber JuicyFox Hackerzzz
wanted to know what would happen
if we put dry ice in our mini Arc furnace.
Well, JFH, we're not sure
what's going to happen
because dry ice is exceptionally cold,
but our many arc furnace
is exceptionally hot.
It gets up to several thousand
degrees in Fahrenheit or Celsius,
and it's easily hot enough
to melt glass, rock, or steel.
What we're going to try
is fairly straightforward.
We'll see how the arc interacts
with the dry ice.
We'll see if it makes it melt
or sublimate faster than normal,
and we'll see if it's any different
with solid pieces of dry ice,
or powdered dry ice.
To start off,
let's see the result
with a solid chunk of dry ice.
I'm also curious to see
how the Arc is going to react
with the dry ice directly,
not the heat from the arc,
but just the arc itself on the dry ice.
[Music]
All right. My first question was to see
how the arc itself interacts with our dry ice.
And unfortunately, while this
does create a very powerful arc,
it doesn't really have
the ability to separate very far.
I'm pretty sure there's very
high amperage,
but very low voltage
running through this thing,
and as a result, it does have
a hard time separating out much.
All right.
I'm going to make the arc,
and I'm going to point it down
and concentrate it on to that dry ice,
and we're going to see
if it does anything.
It might cause it
to sublimate really fast,
or maybe that much electricity and heat
or cause some other unknown reaction.
[Music]
Cool things happening.
First off, with just the arc
concentrated on the dry ice,
it did not melt,
because dry ice does not like to melt
unless you have it under extreme pressure,
and this is just normal
atmospheric pressure.
However, the heat
of the arc was causing
it to sublimate really quickly.
It started dissipating way faster
than putting in the furnace
or anything like that.
It wasn't that quick.
It was still just sort
of a slow disappearance.
But one thing we have learned
about dry ice in the past is that
what makes it sublimate fastest of all is
if it's in physical contact
with something putting out
a lot of heat,
and these carbon rods
put out a lot of heat.
As we have the arc running,
it's heating up whatever's in the furnace,
but it's also heating up
the rods themselves a lot.
You can see that they are glowing orange
when I take them apart from each other,
even when there's no
arc traveling between,
they're still blazing orange hot.
And when I put the hot rods
directly in contact with the dry ice,
that is when we started
seeing it dissipate quickly.
You can see that I've just carved
right down into this piece,
and that was just by touching it
to the rods, which are still hot,
and still causing it
to sublimate quickly on contact.
So by taking the rods,
arcing them together, heating them up,
and then physically touching
them against the dry ice,
that's when we start really seeing
the dry ice get carved away quickly.
That might be the fastest
I've ever seen anything
carve through dry ice.
We're going to do the same thing again,
but on this slightly larger block,
and I'm just going to start poking holes
right down into the surface of the dry ice
with our carbon rods.
[Music]
Those rods turned this dry ice
into just swiss cheese,
like in no time flat.
They just tunnel
right through that.
Look at that, full of holes.
All right, we've got
a little metal nut here,
and we're just going to melt
that right on the dry ice.
Molten metal does a pretty
good job of carving right
through this solid carbon dioxide.
Let's give it a chance.
[Music]
Beautiful.
So that was a nut, now
it's just a ball or a blob.
I don't think I can even call
that ball-shaped.
Melted down in just
a couple of seconds,
and then it started carving it's way,
this beautiful little hole right down
into the dry ice.
One more thing that we want
to test is to see what happens
if we take a bunch of our dry ice,
crush it up into a powder,
and then put that into the arc furnace.
[Music]
Oh, boy!
That was pretty cool.
It's like arching
down inside it.
[Music]
Well, JuicyFox Hackerzzz,
no, we can't quite melt dry ice
in the arc furnace.
We can get it to sublimate
pretty quickly, especially
if we take those blazing hot carbon rods,
and touch them to the dry ice itself.
I also really liked
the look of them.
We had the powdered dry ice
with the rods underneath.
That was a really
cool underglow.
Just all lit up quite a bit.
Looked very neat,
does not melt,
but does do some really cool stuff.
Thank you for your suggestion.
If you check your YouTube inbox,
we'll be sending you 25 bucks.
Remember guys, if you've got a fun idea
of things you want to see us try
on the channel, let us know
down in the comments,
and if we use your idea,
we'll send you $25.
Guys, thanks for watching,
but the fun doesn't end here.
That box up at the top will transport
you directly to our last video,
and you should go check that one out.
The other box will show you what YouTube
thinks you should be watching next,
and if you are not subscribed
to our channel yet,
just hit the bomb to get in the club
and that way you never
miss out on the fun.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we'll see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.